we looked at it thoroughly we
interviewed nearly everybody involved in
the campaign and we didn't find any
collusion with the Russians after 14
months of witness interviews and
hundreds of hours of reviewing raw
intelligence Republicans on the House
Intelligence Committee announced their
work is done with a finding of no
Russian collusion today Senate Democrats
who like their House counterparts were
surprised by the drafts unexpected
release lamb basted the report's authors
the fact that chairman Nunez and
representative Conway cut off the
investigation buried their heads in the
sand and wrote a report that contradicts
17 of our intelligence agencies and a
federal indictment from Special Counsel
Mahler shows were their loyalties lie
Democrats took part in what they
interpreted as one GOP defection Intel
committee Republican Tom Rooney of
Florida said there was a Russian attempt
to assist the Trump campaign I think
that there was efforts to try to hurt
Hillary and help Trump but he added an
important stipulation but I think that
there was also the opposite too while
the president cheered Republicans
findings we're very happy with the
decision by the House Intelligence
Committee saying there was absolutely no
collusion with respect to Russia
it was a very powerful decision House
Intelligence Committee Democrats are
vowing to keep looking for Russian
collusion we're gonna continue to do the
investigation it'll obviously be much
more difficult we've never had the power
to call and witnesses the real action
now turns to the Senate where two
committees intelligence and judiciary
continue their own investigations of
collusion at a pace that has the parties
at odds yet again very bluntly the
Judiciary Committee's investigation has
been painfully and glacially slow the
only collusion investigation that
appears immune from the hyper partisan
influence of this election year is the
one being undertaken by the Justice
Department Inspector General he has no
power to indict but his findings can be
used in a criminal proceeding